um
what you get from me will not be
information
the word guru means this
that goo means darkness
means dispeller one who dispels your
darkness is guru
so you can say you can call guru asad
guru a torchlight if you want
now where do you want to flash it you
tell me that's your questions we'll
decide where we want to flash the
torchlight
do you flash the torchlight
when it's not asked ever or is it only
if it's invited when it's not asked i
have a big light bulb
everything is lit but people cannot see
they need focus light on something
because
they've made their minds like a keyhole
which is the tragedy of human existence
the human experience is so fascinating
to me i
i watch and listen and try and
understand it
but what's the point of it
i know that's kind of a really broad
question but what is the point of it
it's not broad it's a very narrow
question okay
good what you're asking is what's the
point of life yeah
such a question comes because in some
ways become burdensome
if you are ecstatic
you wouldn't ask that question
isn't it
in a moment of great joy you don't ask
that question right you ask that
question because somewhere your feet are
dragging
because you don't have the throttle
under your right foot anymore
good one really good one
so driving back in the car driving at
the speed limit you're feeling what is
the point of life
exactly you understand me so well
but uh speed limits are there
on the regular street
when i first came to united states
nearly 20 22 years ago
because i'm always used to
putting the
throttle to the floorboard wherever i am
if the motorcycle is full on touching
the springs and sometimes cutting off
the springs
because it was never enough
for me
this is a strange thing when i was
riding way back
about five times i cut off that brass uh
one pin will be there inside the
carburetors of a two-stroke engine at
that time we were riding two-stroke
engines
first time it happened i just couldn't
figure out what happened because
if i start the motorcycle it starts if i
try to throttle up it goes off
i took it to somebody who was kind of an
expert
he looked at it and he couldn't figure
it out
not knowing we thought the dynamo is
gone so which the dynamo could be
charged those days only in the
manufacturing unit so we took it there
one whole day i sat there and got it
charged and brought it back still the
same thing
then i realized
it is something unheard of
the brass pin which is in the thing when
you throttle up it comes up and there's
a butterfly around it you know that's
how it was made
so that has gotten cut
because i'm holding the throttle full on
like this
and after that it happened five times
then i knew every time it happened i cut
i always started carrying one extra pin
oh you are my guru
so when in some way you don't live your
life joyfully enough intensely enough
you wonder
what is the point of my existence
because human intelligence is made this
way if it doesn't figure out
if it doesn't figure out all aspects of
life it will feel incomplete
if you had the brains of an earthworm or
a grasshopper you would be fine eating
sleeping reproducing and dying one day
but once you come with this level of
intelligence and awareness
you have to look deeper into your life
because your life is not fixed like
their life
nature has drawn two lines for all of
them they just have to live within that
and go
for you there are no lines
this freedom is what everybody is
suffering
so some people try to go beyond lines by
sitting in a race car some people do it
by doing crime some people do it by
doing adventure yes you see crime yes
that is in a way to break lines
you need to understand because i've i've
worked uh with uh you know like we have
a program called enough freedom for
imprisoned which is mandatory in all
southern indian prisons now
and also we did programs here in
kentucky in pennsylvania tennessee in
other areas in the prisons
i have spent so much time with hardcore
criminals
doing these programs
what i saw was
this is their way of racing
breaking breed speed limits
your way of doing it is you went to the
track if you did the same thing on the
street you would be in the prison yes so
they didn't get sponsored they didn't
get a car they didn't get a machine they
didn't get a situation in their life
where they could create a race is a
controlled uh situation to commit crime
as far as a local trooper is concerned
i'm saying yeah yes yeah it's a
controlled atmosphere where it's made
reasonably safe for everybody
the risk is only for those who want who
have that madness in them
but if you do it on the street the risk
is for everybody so it becomes a crime
but it's the same thing
if you have a high-powered car on the
street and you race when i first came to
united states
i thought what is the problem because i
am not i'm never going to drive in such
a way it's going to be dangerous for
somebody else
but if i'm not on the edge of danger i
can't live
okay
so i'm like hitting it really full
throttle and people are saying
you should not drive like this in
america it's not like india you can
drive at your own speed people in india
do drive crazy so fast yes so fast
i drive much faster in india than i do
in america wow so first couple of visits
i made i'm driving i said what's the
problem there's power in the engine and
the road is wide open what is it
no no you can't do this they'll handcuff
you they'll do this i said why
then i don't listen to what others say i
just observe then i see
a 80 year old woman is driving a school
bus and going if i go whoosh
she may go fall off somewhere all right
so then i
understood the speed limits